I guess I don't want to talk about the thing that all three of us would be
wanting to ask. Yeah. I mean,
as an animator on Twitter and everything like that, I didn't matter. Yeah.
You're European European. You, your opinion matters. All opinion doesn't mean,
your opinion. On the other hand, it means a lot. Yeah.
Like how would you feel about, you know,
artists and animators getting backlash after an episode has
aired, for example, attack on Titan. Yeah. I would say it,
people are very, very angry and have been sending even I think death threats
and animators on Twitter and stuff like that.
And it's just that scare you or anything like that? Working on projects.
If I had those kind of treads, I will be, Oh, I messed up that.
[Inaudible].
In my case, my it's just Twitter internet.
I don't have time to bother about that. I have to consider it in my car.
Yeah, exactly.
So, yeah,
but the four people who gave it or the girl didn't sleep managed to,
to deliver the wizard and receive all the threats, it's a bit, it's a bit.
It's pulled off to deal with threats at work.
Yeah. And I think most of you need me to is known. So walking up,
I couldn't get a good well,
but I managed to [inaudible] and they know their level and they want
to progress to good. Everybody wants to do a good episode,
want to make a quality better.
You have to manage it with the amount of scheduled amount of money. Uh,
and it's, uh, yes, it's very hard.
And sometimes you and I mentioned a good
schedule, a good there's something good going well, doesn't things.
If you have a lot of preventative programs you have to adjust to.
It's not just like the problem of like, you know, the single animator, right.
It's like, there's a lot of things that the animator probably has to juggle,
but like, yeah. Like, you know, both say for example,
like I would maybe understand a little more if even the animator looked at what
they did and was like, yeah, that wasn't my best work,
but this is a toggle of time with you. And it's been pretty amazing so far.
Have you been following the episodes of watches? The last one?
For some reason, I'm very vocal. They're like, Oh, it's terrible.
Now the animation quality is terrible.
Most of the people don't like the CGI. Yeah. And yeah,
if you are used to, um, something that you wish that you have done
[inaudible] yeah. And now it's a, we CJ actually me too, when I see, Oh,
this isn't your job or I'm beat. I prefer it. It was our more on taco go.
I don't understand.
Yeah. But, but you could say that because you'll eat.
So some of the immune says, Oh, she's used,
I would prefer [inaudible]. But there is not a reason to, to.
People like the shows ruined the seats.
The CGI has ruined my show and it's like, why, why does your brain?
It's so bizarre.
People are also complaining about some of the soccer guys as well. Really? Yeah.
I've been seeing that, like, you know, some, some, uh,
I've seen some people on Twitter. It's been awesome.
Some people on Twitter have, you know,
like done comparisons with like the Munga panels, for example,
and being like completely ruined. It's not exactly the same. Right?
Like how do you feel about stuff like that? They pushed him.
Cause, cause I've always wanted, cause you've worked on some pretty high praise.
Do you ever have this problem as well? Do you ever, like when working on it,
do you ever like feel the pressure whenever you're working on a big IP need to
and want to deliver?
Very, um, I know that most of the,
when I post something of my Ganga, uh,
in Twitter is not my animation. They have likes it's more, the,
the IP has likes, right. People don't, I don't know.
Most of the people like puts it like, or the retreat. Oh. But because it's my,
I like this IP.
Yeah. No, because like Joe, Joe, Joe fans. Right.
I did see on your screen.
Sure. Yeah. I think it was my Georgia had the most, uh,
retreats.
Uh, she, uh, uh, I think I saw the animation that you did for that. Uh
[inaudible] that's like literally like the best fight in port for like so good.
And it was amazing. Oh man, it was so hard to this day.
Yeah. It was in 2018. Yeah. It was Christmas.
And I spend, or my Christmas and new year at working at this table.
I spent three weeks at sleeping,
under study to finish sleeping at the studio for the fight
because I had to finish the heroic layout. And after he broke, I had a mayor.
The, a layout while you're working on the Jojo game though.
I finished her here.
I came back and uh,
and the deadline was like the 10th. So January.
And so most of my coworkers are went to what was a typical.
So most of it was in France, French people. So they went back to France.
I spend the new year and I came back and this is when they
went to France. It was, I had no beer. And when they came back, I had to be.
[Inaudible] became a home.
And uh, so I was going to, uh, uh,
go gym to have my shower.
So when you went, like the case where like, if you were that all the time,
you're putting, like, were you just thinking about it in the shower as well?
You're like thinking about what you were going to draw next as well.
Yeah. Show it takes time, but sometimes you can quit.
Each house may smell bad. I have to take a shower.
So to optimize your showers, it's just like,
do you ever get to the point when you're just like eating too much time?
I was eating, watching an episode eating and okay.
Zippy's had finished AFF it finished to eat. Okay. To go back to work.
You're welcome, Joseph. Yeah.
So yes. Yeah. And I get sick also.
I think I know him.
He's a bad one or I have a inference of how do we say in influenza you
get infringed.
You got flu,
literally killing yourself with Joe friends. Uh,
you can say you were.
I was trying to do my best on this one.
I think Olivia would argue that's one of the best fight scenes in part five.
Yeah. Think it looks amazing as well. Yeah. I think we'll all have part five.
Everyone could tell I just saying that. Yeah, no, it's definitely crowdfund.
Uh, animations is a teamwork. So like I said,
I do the rough animation with the jerks to put some correction.
So something that was a two liter, how can I say, Oh,
you can push more this arm. The director will put it in. After the,
the director of animation, we put the Mo more in model.
Right.
And so these three tips are very important after I hae received this correction.
I original it. Everything was all the detailed,
all the shadows or the light or the perfect frames. So yes,
it's a teamwork. And after these drawings,
it will be the in-betweener who will cleanup.
And it's a very, a team walkie. It's not just one.
Animator's walk. You have the director,
the director of animations in between are the color.
Um, um, I'm, I'm curious. It's gonna be a dumb question. Uh,
do you like here when you're drawing it, I assume,
is the voice acting records at that point? Or is it not recorded? No, it's,
it's tough to, Oh, wow. It's acting as post-production. Yeah. Oh, wow.
So you don't even get to like, hear the lines as you're drawing or anything.
Sometimes you have, uh, some, um, a rough voice. Right. But it's not, uh,
the finer of it.
That's right. Yeah. It's mostly, it's mostly just like,
I think it's written out in the layout section right. Of what the actual,
what they're going to say in this particular class.
Every board at the storyboard. And after you have the time sheet,
when at this moment you have to have it.
Oh. And then the voice actors match that. Yeah. Yeah.
So all animators dubbed anime. Yeah. Yeah. It is done. Yeah. Wow.
[inaudible].